y miles de ucranianos huyen de la guerra
más de 500 mil refugiados han huido
ahora de ucrania de los países vecinos
la travesía puede durar hasta cuatro
días saliendo en automóvil desde
territorio ucraniano los principales
destinos a los que se dirigen los
refugiados son polonia rumanía
eslovaquia y hungría los tiempos de
espera para cruzar pueden ser de hasta
un día en esta ciudad fronteriza entre
polonia y ucrania los refugiados muchos
de ellos mujeres y niños esperan para
abordar autobuses que nos llevarán a
sitios seguros
como un tren desde el ibis para llegar
aquí fue muy difícil había mucha gente
fue muy aterrador y peligroso física y
mentalmente
desde polonia los refugiados con
pasaporte o documento de identidad
ucraniano pueden viajar de forma
gratuita en tren hasta berlín
[Música]
la situación estaba caldeada en kiev y
odessa la ciudad más cercana para
nosotros sí o de esa calle no tendríamos
ninguna posibilidad así que decidimos
irnos con mi familia
[Música]
un deleite
voluntarios en las estaciones los
reciben y ayudan a orientarse en la
capital alemana alicantina
hay mucha gente que llega aquí los
recogen porque tienen amigos y parientes
y otros llegan y no tienen un plan a
dónde ir y qué hacer y la mayoría de
ellos están realmente cansados
y
el panorama no es diferente en rumanía
hayan instalado decenas de tiendas de
campaña y los refugiados reciben
alimentos y ayuda de la cruz roja' la
unión europea en una reunión de
ministros del interior planteó la
posibilidad de otorgar a los ucranianos
un estatus bajo una directiva de
protección temporal de 2001 aún no
utilizada que les permitiría vivir y
trabajar en la unión europea por hasta
tres años